the right candidate with the right
policies that America desperately needs
today would never win an election today
why because the right policies would be
folks guess what if you vote for me
we're cutting back on fifty percent of
entitlement programs we're cutting back
on unemployment checks we're going to go
from six months to 90 days to 30 days
we're cutting back on all this spending
that we're doing we're cutting back on
the military spending that we're doing
we're going to put it more in cyber and
bio Warfare and being prepared for that
because right now Wars are not going to
be done up there it's going to be more
cyber what Russia is doing but we're
gonna you're gonna have to get to work
the next eight to 12 years because we
all have a job to do no one would vote
for you even though those are the right
policies nobody would vote for you right
okay so
how many presidents become presidents
and they make policies that benefit you
30 years from now nobody nobody does
that